[Music]
so hi my name is Gareth Thomas I'm here
at Pi data eindhaven this is the biggest
paid AI event in Ironton also one of the
committee members of biodata we've been
doing this for four years this is the
first time that we've done it the spirit
of this is sharing knowledge so it's
technical talks with technical people we
all build a community we stand on the
shoulders of giants and this is how we
become stronger as a community by
sharing knowledge with different
stakeholders
[Music]
hi my name is Rick and I work with
internet engagement at asml I am borja
I'm a tomato freak in the internet
casual team yeah and we're here today to
spread awareness about what asml is what
we're doing and what especially what
we're doing with data science at asml
[Music]
I'm Balto from Owen I'm demonstrating
some micro python applications here you
can see some boards and some
applications and that's all run with
python on small bike withdrawal chips
foreign
[Music]
toven and I'm the co-founder and chief
product officer at preserve we're trying
to build a development environment for
data scientists that is interactive and
exploratory but also stable enough to do
serious work it
hi my name is yellow I'm here with
iterative and iterative builds machine
learning tools such as DVC CML and MLM
and we're here today to teach you about
those tools they're all open source yeah
hopefully you can use them to make your
model training easier and generally
model development easier so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]